pop
[Musique]
l'audience est ouverte
veuillez vous asseoir accusés quels sont
le nom et prénom comme si vous ne saviez
pas je vous prie de répondre à ma
question quels sont vos noms et prénoms
lambert michel pieyre dates et lieux de
votre naissance 1er mars 36 alger prénom
de votre père jacques nom et prénom de
votre mère josette planès et vous il va
être procédé à l'appel des jurés vous
voudrez bien répondre présent et au fur
et à mesure je mettrais vos noms dans le
sud est monsieur blon des maisons à la
france si monsieur bon tu sais si tu vas
exemple lame du boucher et monsieur
petit poucet maintenant que richard
gardet marc venturi un beau un second
qui est présent monsieur michaud c'est
ce que nous faisons ne sert qu'à dire
présentait lundi liu parce que le sou
raison du black bear fait
accusés il va être procédé au tirage au
sort du jury chargé de vous juger
je rappelle à monsieur l'avocat général
et à la défense leur droit de récusation
alors mesdames et messieurs vous voudrez
bien prendre place aux côtés de la cour
dans l'ordre fixé par le sort alors je
vais te tirer au sort
monsieur andré casanova sur votre
qualité de premier juré ou signerait la
feuille des questions avec nous qu'on
ait place aux côtés de la cour
madame michèle dillo monsieur henri
guichard
monsieur etienne bon crochet et monsieur
monsieur fernand cintrée
madame france toury monsieur andré
cordier madame annick gaucher est
neuvième et dernier jurés sauf
récusation monsieur david bangs
alors monsieur le greffier veuillez
faire s'il vous plaît l'appel du jury le
jury le jugement est composé de monsieur
casanova madame guillaume ceux qui
forment ce que bon monsieur st très
madame touré que ce cordier manfred
monsieur banques eet non mesdames et
messieurs les jurés
veuillez vous lever mesdames et
messieurs la cour va recevoir votre
serment voudrait bien la main levée dire
je jure la main droite vous jurer et
prom était d'examiner avec l'attention
la plus scrupuleuse les sharks qui
seront portées contre lambert michel
pieyre de ne trahir ni les intérêts de
l'accusé ni ceux de la société qui
l'accusent de ne communiquer avec
personne
jusqu'après votre déclaration de
n'écouter ni la haine ou la méchanceté
ni la crainte ou l'affection de vous
décider
d'après les charges et des moyens de
défense suivant votre conscience et
votre intime conviction avec
l'impartialité et la fermeté qui
conviennent à un homme probe et libre et
de conserver le secret des délibérations
même après la cessation de vos fonctions
sur très fier lesieu andré casanova
bonjour
madame michèle riot monsieur henri
guichard jaugeurs monsieur etienne bon
le jeu
monsieur fernand saint très peu chère
madame france toury cher
monsieur andré cordier ce jeu madame
annick gaucher et monsieur david ban ki
moon sur nos racines
la cour vous donne acte de votre serment
je déclare le jury définitivement
constitué les autres jurés peuvent se
retirer
monsieur l'huissier voudrait bien faire
l'appel des témoins tout s'il vous plaît
que témoin cité par le ministère public
monsieur ni faire monsieur tavernay
monsieur mauléon mademoiselle raclée que
ce que peut être vicieux petrovic
présent monsieur le rêve par exemple
monsieur calvi maison témoin cité par la
défense monsieur péladeau dépôt monsieur
le président on le fera monter quand
voudrait l'entendre
très bien alors la suite s'il vous plaît
mademoiselle eu bras vibrer à présente
excuse alors que les témoins se retire
dans la salle qui leur est réservé ils
ne pourront sortir que pour venir
déposer accusés soyez attentifs à ce que
vous allez entendre monsieur le greffier
la donner lecture de l'arrêt qui vous
renvoie devant cette cour d'assises
la chambre d'accusation de la cour
d'appel de paris a rendu l'arrêt non
l'entraîneur suivent la cour à présent
avoir délibéré conformément à la loi
considère que des pièces de
l'instruction résulte les faits suivants
en décembre 1973
lambert est en forme et le projet de
commettre une agression contre un
établissement bancaire de la banlieue
parisienne pris contact avec divers
repris de justice pour trouver des
complices c'est ainsi que le mercredi 26
décembre il devait rencontrer le nommer
farès au domicile de ces derniers
14 rue andré costes à villeneuve le roi
val de marne
la police ayant eu vent de ce
rendez-vous et lambert faisant l'objet
d'un mandat d'arrêt pour un cambriolage
commis antérieurement
des inspecteurs de la 11e brigade
territoriale décidèrent de l'appréhender
lors de son arrivée chez varetz à mes
lombaires réussit à se réfugier dans
l'appartement voisin où se trouvait la
dame petrovic musicale ainsi que ses
deux enfants une voisine
lambert qui étaient armés menaçaient
d'abattre ces quatre personnes
si la police ne lui laissait pas quitter
librement l'immeuble les tractations ont
lieu au cours desquelles lambert exigera
également que l'on mette à sa
disposition un véhicule automobile
une forte somme d'argent bien que les
autorités aient donné leur accord
lambert a bâti successivement deux de
ses étals avant de prendre la fuite en
entraînant avec lui un troisième qu'il
devait libérer quelques heures plus tard
après avoir acquis la certitude que la
police avait perdu sa trace interpellé
par la gendarmerie de 18 janvier 1914 à
jullouville mange lambert fit à nouveau
usage de son arme et blessé trois
personnes avant d'être appréhendé dit
que les pieds c'est l'instruction
résulte de charges suffisantes contre
laon père michel pieyre premièrement
d'avoir à villeneuve-le-roi le 26
décembre 1913 commis un homicide
volontaire sur la personne de petrovic
ruzicka deuxièmement d'avoir dans les
mêmes circonstances de temps et de lieu
commis un homicide volontaire sur la
personne de petrovic jovan avec cette
circonstance que ledit thomis qui de
volontaires commis sur la personne de
petrovic ruzicka a précédé accompagné ou
suivi le dit homicide volontaire commis
sur la personne de petrovic aux vans
troisièmement d'avoir dans les mêmes
circonstances de temps et de lieu
détenue et séquestrée la demoiselle
rappelé sylvie et la demoiselle fait
trop vif sofia avec ces circonstances
que les personnes détenues et séquestré
l'ont été comme otages pour favoriser la
fuite et assurer l'impunité de l'auteur
d'un crime
avec ces circonstances que les personnes
détenues et séquestrés ont été menacés
de mort
quatrièmement d'avoir deux mêmes
circonstances de temps et de lieu porté
des coups et fait des blessures la
demoiselle raclée sylvie les des
blessures des dix coups ayant entraîné
une incapacité de travail supérieure à
huit jours cinquièmement d'avoir à
jullouville le mange le 18 janvier 1914
tenté de donner volontairement la mort à
veauche et morteau et gandrey tentative
qui a été manifestée par un commencement
d'exécution et qui n'a manqué son effet
que par des circonstances indépendantes
de la volonté de son auteur
sixièmement d'avoir dans les mêmes
circonstances de temps et de lieu
détenus sans autorisation des armes et
des munitions de 4e catégorie crimes et
délits connexes prévus et réprimés par
les articles 225 1 304 309 341 343 144
du code pénal et par les articles 20 28
38 30 5 du décret loi du 18 avril 1139
modifié par le décret du 12 mars 1973
prononce la mise en accusation de l'an
père michel querre elle renvoie devant
la cour d'assises si l on à paris pour y
être jugé merci monsieur le greffier
lambert levé vous lever vous lambert
vous avez été placé sous mandat de dépôt
le 18 janvier 1974 et vous vous trouvez
depuis cette date sous le régime de la
détention provisoire
alors avant votre arrestation vun
exerciez aucune profession
vous êtes célibataire mais pas d'enfant
et vous avez fait l'objet déjà de
plusieurs condamnations nous comparer
c'est devant cette cour d'assises des
chefs d'inculpation dont lecture vient
d'être donné et vous êtes à ce titre un
cible de la peine de mort vous allez
être jugé aujourd'hui tout au long de
votre procès vous pourrez vous exprimer
librement
est-ce bien clair j'en ai à [ __ ] vous
avez décidé de me juger alors juger moi
tous les trois ans et moins vers ça
suffit je croyais que je pourrais
m'exprimer librement sur les faits oui
mais pas pour insulter la cour et le
jury
je me tate rester debout
je suis nue assise je vous ordonne de
vous lever
lambert lambert je vous conseille de ne
pas persister dans cette attitude qui
nous vaudra certainement pas
l'indulgence du jeu je vais procéder à
votre interrogatoire jeu retracerait
d'abord votre curriculum vitae et
ensuite nous examinerons les faits qui
motive votre comparution vous êtes né le
1er mars 1936 à alger votre père était
inspecteur des contributions directes
vous avez une soeur josiane vos parents
formaient un couple très uni et votre
enfance où s'est déroulée dans une
excellente ambiance familiale alors
après votre baccalauréat que vous avez
obtenus en 1954 par conséquent à l'âge
de 18 ans vous avez trouvé du travail
dans une entreprise de transport
maritime dont le directeur était un ami
de votre père vous résidiez toujours
chez vos parents et avec votre soeur
josiane vous fréquentiez des jeunes gens
issus du même milieu que vous c'est à
dire en gros la bonne bourgeoisie
d'alger mai
les camarades que vous aviez qu'on a pu
retrouver ont déclaré aux enquêteurs que
vous étiez coléreux violent cherchant
toujours la bagarre alors au cours de
l'été 1955 fait la connaissance d'un
certain paul gray si avec lequel vous
devenez très vite inséparables
ce pôle récit de deux ans votre aîné
avait déjà un lourd passé de délinquant
le saviez vous naturellement et ça ne
vous a pas empêché de continuer à le
fréquenter
pourquoi pas en janvier 1956 gré si vous
entraîner dans un coup le cambriolage
d'une villa déserte dans la banlieue
d'alger va pas entraîner c'est moi qui
avait tout organisé
les tribunaux d'alger en ont jugé
autrement puisqu'ils ont infligé cinq
années de prison aux nommés gressy
tandis qu'il ne vous condamnez vous qu à
deux ans avec sursis
je souhaitais bien défendu et voilà tout
bon admettons vous faites alors votre
service militaire et vous participer aux
opérations du maintien de l'ordre en
algérie
votre conduite sur le terrain est
exemplaire et vous êtes deux fois cité
mais il n'en va pas de même quand votre
unité est au repos je lis
insubordination violences et voies de
fait sur la personne d'un sous-officier
bris de matériel et 8 ans et j'en passe
à la fin 2009 157 vous êtes démobilisés
vos parents vous propose de retourner
vivre chez eux alors vous refusez
pourquoi avez vous refusé la famille
j'en avais ras le bol
installés alors à oran fréquenter des
milieux peu recommandables des
proxénètes et des malfaiteurs au mois de
mars
votre responsabilité est engagée dans
une affaire de vol qualifié vous cacher
pour échapper à la police
mais six semaines plus tard vous
participez à une agression à main armée
au cours de laquelle un employé de
banque est blessé et vous êtes et croit
la cour d'assises d'alger devant
laquelle vous comparaissez en avril 1959
nous infliger six ans de réclusion
criminelle dont vous plonger votre peine
en métropole et fin 1961 vous bénéficiez
d'une mesure de libération anticipée
après avoir accompli presque quatre ans
de détention
vous installez alors à marseille
pourquoi n'êtes vous pas retourner à
alger avec les événements merci très peu
pour moi
enfin aux parents ils résident est
toujours votre mère était même très
malade ne pas aller la voir à quoi
aurait servi
et puis tous mes copains tête à
marseille quelques copains des copains
vous aviez connu en prison a bien sûr
que ceux d'avant depuis le temps alors
que faisiez-vous à marseille je
travaillais pour monsieur calvi ange
calvi j'avais connu un sega en taule
m'avait recommandé alors monsieur calvi
m'a embauché tout de suite vous
embaucher pour faire quoi
j'étais barman dans une de ces boîtes de
nuit le rien fectivement vous étiez
barman mais vous aviez aussi d'autres
activités moins avouables pendant le
premier semestre
pardon le premier trimestre 1962 vous
avez pris part à trois hold up dont l'un
le dernier s'est terminé de façon
tragique puisque vous avez abattu un
gardien de nuit dans des conditions
particulièrement horribles quand on fait
ce que tu es là on sait qu'on prend des
risques
quel métier et gangsters dont trois mois
à l'autre gardien de nuit vous êtes
arrêté ainsi que vos complices et vous
êtes traduit une nouvelle fois devant
une cour d'assises
le 18 avril 1963 les jurés des bouches
du rhône vous condamne pour vol qualifié
homicide volontaire
à treize années de réclusion criminelle
s'était cher enfin vous aviez tué un
homme lambert vous étiez passible de la
peine de mort vous avez été condamné à
13 ans de réclusion criminelle ne vous
plaignez pas au cours de votre détention
à la centrale d'eysses un incident s'est
produit détenu a été tué à coups de
couteau au cours de la promenade dans
des circonstances assez obscur de
notoriété publique vous étiez en très
mauvais termes avec lui vous l'aviez
même menacé de mort à plusieurs reprises
le couteau vous appartenait et l'homme
avant de mourir vous a formellement
accusé
mais d'autres détenus ont affirmé que
vous étiez avec eux au moment du crime
dans une autre partie de la cour et que
vous ne pouviez être le meurtrier
l'enquète n'a pu apporter la preuve de
votre culpabilité et vous avez bénéficié
d'un non lieu
les a pas empêchés de tout 60 jours de
mitard puis pour menaces et détention
d'armes prohibées
vous avez été transférée à la maison
centrale de clairvaux vous avez fini de
purger votre peine vote relevé des coûts
a été signé je vois le 7 novembre 1973
vous avez aussitôt gagné paris pour
quelle raison je vais pas vous allez
justement alors pourquoi paris un copain
clairvaux mais il parlait d'une fille j
qui en me disant que je pourrais
m'installer chez elle mégi qui je
présume que c'est simone bolelli pour m6
et la noise l ubaye brigitte sy c'est
son nom de travail alors vous êtes
installé chez elle au début de novembre
qu'avez-vous fait jusqu'au 26 décembre
j'ai commencé d'abord par me reposer
après 12 ans de taule n'a besoin de
reprendre des forces
vous êtes reposé pendant deux mois et de
quoi viviez vous vous allez de l'argent
non j'estime en avait avancé
et c'est sans doute pour la rembourser
que le 30 novembre vous avez commis un
cambriolage à la neil près de noailles
et cambriolages dont d'ailleurs nous ne
parlerons pas puisque le cas a été
disjoint la perse et ans passés dans
l'oise vous serez jugés ultérieurement
avec vos complices par la cour d'assises
de bové bon et bien voilà à peu près
tout ce que l'on peut dire de votre vie
avant le mois de décembre 1973 avait
quelque chose à ajouter façon ce que je
pourrais dire des questions mesdames et
messieurs les jurés
monsieur l'avocat général oui monsieur
le président lambert quand vous avez été
arrêté en 1962 après le meurtre du
guardian nuit vous avez déclaré aux
enquêteurs que les agressions dont vous
vous étiez rendus coupables avaient été
commises à l'instigation d'ange calvi et
que vous aviez seulement exécuté les
ordres de votre patron un peu plus tard
au cours de l'instruction vous êtes
revenu sur ses déclarations et vous avez
affirmé que calvin était pour rien dans
ces 3 août
vous avez même précisé que vous ne
connaissiez pas que vous ne l'aviez
jamais rencontré comment expliquez vous
ces contradictions les flics m'avait
adressé j'ai dit n'importe quoi pour qui
veut la paix les brutalités policières
royer malheureusement je constate que
vos complices arrêtés et interrogés en
même temps vous n'ont pas fait la
moindre allusion à calvi pour eux il n'y
avait qu'un seul patron vous lambert le
président henri m messieurs président
dois-je rappeler à monsieur l'avocat
général que l' affaire à laquelle il
fait allusion a été jugé en 1963 il ya
de cela plus de 12 ans avez vous
l'intention d'en refaire l'instruction
dans le nord mais tranquillisez vous
j'ai seulement voulu mettre en lumière
un certain traits de caractère de votre
client dont j'aurai d'ailleurs
l'occasion de reparler
l'addition alors nous en venons
maintenant au mois de décembre 1973 et
aux faits qui vous sont reprochés
or après ce cambriolage dans l'oise
d'heuliez l'intention de commettre une
nouvelle agression contre une agence de
banlieue de la banque commerciale et
industrielle et vous avez cherché des
complices vous avez dans cette intention
rencontré un certain rené varech ce
message pour dire que c'est un coup de
pot vous avez vu varetz une première
fois je vois le 21 décembre
il vous a dit que la sphère ne
l'intéressait pas personnellement mes
clips pouvez vous mettre en relation
d'autres personnes des repris de justice
bien entendant bien entendu pardon
susceptibles de vous aider et un
rendez-vous un nouveau rendez vous a été
pris pour le 26 décembre à midi chez
varetz 14 rue andré crossed à villeneuve
le roi
c'est bien ça oui le numéro 14 mesdames
et messieurs correspond en réalité à
cinq immeubles de construction assez
récente qui entoure une sorte de cour
jardin
alors chaque immeuble en aux étages et
barrett habite dans le bâtiment 3 au 9e
étage la porte c'est parce qu'il ya
quatre appartements 4 logements par
étapes donc alors le 26 décembre
lendemain de noël
par conséquent vous arrivez villeneuve
le roi chez barrette au lieu d'aller à
12 heures comme pic c'est d'arriver à
13h15 pourquoi ce retard je ne courais
pas après ça faisait du bien de marine
est un peu désarmée
bien sûr alors vous êtes monté au 9e
étage vous avez sonné à la porte de la
route non il ya des soupçons
non on m'avait dit qu'il était réguler
je pense avoir cette ordure m'avait
donné alors pourquoi n'avez-vous pas
sonné le pif et tout de suite senti que
quelque chose ne tourner pas rond
il y avait un coup fourré quelque part
alors j'ai attendu un petit peu pour
voir sans faire de bruit donc on sache
pas s'il était toujours là sa part été
long j'ai entendu un pas dans l'escalier
quelqu'un qui descendent étage au dessus
tout doucement puis plus rien le gars
était arrêté alors je suis tout de suite
compris qu'on me prenait pour un cave
c'était un poulet qui faisait la planque
il y avait sûrement son frère jumeau qui
m'attend déchets par ex ce sont des
mauvais alors que j'avais à faire
c'était me tire en vitesse c'est donc
voilà l'ascenseur était plus là
quelqu'un l'avait appelée descendre par
l'escalier 0 et seront de poule à
l'étagé au dessous sont bloqués j'étais
fait comme un débutant
heureusement la porte derrière moi s'est
ouverte la porte des sels de
l'appartement occupé par monsieur madame
et roddick
oui j'ai vu une fille quand sortait
alors j'ai fait rentrer la tête dans le
gymnase est craquelée n'est ce pas c'est
une voisine
écoutez si vous me dérober tout en moi
je dis plus rien c'est bien je vous
laisse parler bon alors si j'ai fait
rentrer la fille dans le logement qui
vont avec
ils étaient trois là une bonne femme en
robe de chambre et puis de mots je leur
ai dit que si ce n'est peinard il leur
arrive rien voilà la bonne femme s'est
mise à gueuler que les mômes avec les
ayant permis tous les quatre dans une
chambre la femme qui criait était madame
petrovic qui habitait là avec son mari
et leurs deux enfants le petit ovale un
garçonnet de 4 ans et une petite fille
de 6 ans sofia
tous quatre nationalité yougoslave quant
à mademoiselle raclée c'est une voisine
elle était venue aider madame petrovic
était souffrante a préparé le repas des
enfants levé vous lambert
vous avez donc enfermé ces quatre
personnes dans une chambre et ensuite
qu'avez vous fait vous savez tout
valeurs dites le vous même les policiers
qui se trouvait sur le palier en essayer
de vous parler de vous raisonner mais
vous les avaient injuriés vous avez même
tiré un coup de revolver à travers la
porte dans le commissaire tavernier qui
dirige la 11e brigade territoriale est
arrivé quelques minutes plus tard puis
le commissaire talleyrand oui monsieur
dame la maison poulaga en grande pompe
cinq prix le commissaire taverny a tenté
lui aussi deux parlementaires avec vous
en pure perte
vous avez refusé de libérer vos otages
et vous avez formulé vos premières
exigences une voiture pour vous enfuir
et l'assurance que la police ne serait
pas de vous arrêter
il était à ce moment-là 13h41 le
commissaire taverne est acceptée il n'a
rien accepté du to fight vous savez il a
dit qu'il était d'accord et mais quand
il a très vite la voiture et est en bas
que je me suis mis à la tête de la
chambre voir si célébrer la rue grouille
et de flics
c'était pas pour me faire une haie
d'honneur quand je passerai non alors
menacé d'abattre un de vos otages si la
rue n'était pas évacuer immédiatement
enfin quand je dis la rue l'immeuble
également je tenais pas avoir d'effets
ricard sur chaque palier vous avez aussi
demandé que l'on dépose 50 mille francs
nouveau c'est à dire 5 millions anciens
sur la banquette de la voiture au pays
où l'essence
alors ensuite qu'avez vous fait j'étais
dans la cuisine pour manger un morceau
je commençais à avoir faim vos otages
étaient toujours enfermés dans la champ
la bonne femme et mon wii continue à
broyer dans son sabir alors je me dis
que si c'était dépenses allait mal finir
autant souffrir dans les violons plus ça
allait plus l de lait comme petrovic
étaient de nationalité yougoslave
parlait à peine le français le comprenez
très mal maintenant ça je pourrais pas
le deviner
alors vous l'avez frappée oui tu cru
comme sac qu'elle comprendrait
puisqu'elle a bouclerait un moment plus
tard le commissaire taverne et vous a
annoncé par mégaphone que tout était
prêt l'immeuble et la rue était bâclé la
voiture était dans la porte avec l'arc
ouais il avait oublié de parler des
tireurs quelques erreurs y avait un
tireur sur le point de coûter de la rue
y avait un pistolet mitrailleur
je connais on avait les mêmes en algérie
essayer de se planquer derrière une
cheminée mais le litre au père alors âgé
j'ai compris qu'on prenait pour un cave
donc je leur montrerai parti c'est du
sérieux
mais j'essaierai nos baisers panda
fallait leur donner une leçon ce n'est
pas à la police que vous avez donné une
leçon comme vous dites c'est un même
petrovic et m'emmerder avec sur le mans
et puis juste au moment où joe perry
tireur et elle est partie en courant
vers la porte d'entrée pour essayer de
filet on vous l'avait rattrapé il vous
l'avait abattu froidement d'une balle
dans la tête
net
la pole temps de souffrir vous avez
lancé un nouvel ultimatum
si tous les tireurs ne disparaissaient
pas vous turier un deuxième otage mais
enfin qu'est ce que je pouvais faire
d'autre il voulait pas comprendre
marquer sa part servi à grand chose
est-ce que dix minutes plus tard j'ai
entendu l'ascenseur yahvé nouveau
quelqu'un dans l'immeuble c'est à ce
moment-là que j'ai piqué un coup de sang
et vous avez tué le petit ovale le
jetant par la fenêtre du neuvième étage
ouais mais tout ça c'est la faute aux
poulets parce que s'ils savaient pas ce
que leur demandait pas dire à paul
bourbeau est la suite de ce nouveau
meurtre deux otages étaient encore entre
vos mains
mademoiselle raclée et la petite sofia
alors je vois qu à 15h45 vous sortez de
l'immeuble en tenant dans vos bras la
petite fille dont vous servait comme
d'un bouclier ou était mademoiselle
racler la petite suffisamment protégé
l'autre amour est plutôt gêné bon bah je
l'avais laissée en eau près d'avoir
assommé
je dépense qui me court après la voiture
mise à votre disposition par la police
était devant la porte de l'immeuble vous
vous y êtes engouffrés avec l'enfant et
vous avez démarré aussitôt il était 16
heures 55 quand après avoir circulé sur
différentes routes de la vallée de
chevreuse vous vous êtes arrêté à
châteaufort en yvelines est là sous la
menace de votre arme
vous avez volé une autre voiture parce
que la première devait d'être un piège à
cons
les flics y avait sûrement installer un
émetteur et me suivent à la trace
alors tant que j'avais la petite avec
moi je dis rien nous avions trop peur
que je descende je peux pas la garder
toute la vie alors je vois qu'au cours
de l'après midi vous avez changé trois
fois de voitures ont les volants à
chaque fois et un entendu alors
finalement vers deux heures du matin un
automobiliste a trouvé la petite sofia
et bt les transits froid au bord d'une
route dans la forêt de montargis j'étais
sûre d'avoir semer les poulets alors
j'avais plus besoin d'elle la police
avait effectivement perdu votre trace il
a fallu plus de trois semaines doivent
retrouver ce n'est que le 18 janvier que
vous avez été arrêté à jullouville dans
la main dans la dans la manche c'est ça
l'arrestation mouvementée puisque vous
avez blessé trois personnes deux
gendarmes et un passant j'étais sûr
qu'il ne fait pas de cadeau j'ai défendu
c'est tout alors en exécution du mandat
d'arrêt lancé contre vous vous avez été
transféré à paris et le juge
d'instruction s'est saisi du dossier de
jullouville pour une bonne
administration de la justice vous êtes
donc jugé également aujourd'hui pour
cette tentative d'homicide volontaire
sur des agents de la force publique dans
l'exercice de leurs fonctions bien
nous reviendrons sur tous ces événements
avec l'audition des témoins êtes vous
d'accord avec la relation des faits que
je viens de faire ou avez-vous quelque
quelque chose a ajouté une observation
dont neuf dans l'ensemble ça s'est passé
à peu près comme ça non il n'y a rien
d'autre à dire alors des questions
mesdames et messieurs
monsieur l'avocat général oui je
voudrais revenir sur ce ce tireur à la
mitraillette que lambert prétend avoir
aperçu sur le toit je constate qu'il a
mentionné pour la première fois le 29
avril seulement au cours de son
quatrième interrogatoire par le juge
d'instruction c'est à dire trois mois et
demi après son incarcération pardon j'en
ai parlé aux juges la première fois que
je les ai vus alors que le procès verbal
d'interrogatoire n'en fasse pas mention
malgré qu'ils avaient oublié s'en
foutait complètement il passait son
temps à se curer les oreilles lui taper
là mais si oui mais vos os que vous
l'avez signé un procès verbal et votre
défenseur était présent j'imagine alors
comment expliquez-vous qu'il n'ait pas
relevé une omission aussi grave dans
lambert non vous n'avez pas parlé de ce
tireur
parce qu'ils n'existaient pas vous
l'avez inventé tardivement pour tenter
d'obtenir justification au meurtre de
madame petrovic à meurtre gratuit et que
rien justement de plus justifiée mais
c'est le président jouant président je
me lève contre le terme de crime gratuit
qui a employé le ministère public
lambert défendez sa liberté dans un
moment d'égarement et l'a cru que la vie
de deux personnes en étaient le prix ce
double crime est affreuse certes mais
lambert n'a pas tué gratuitement
il a tué pour se protéger pour se
défendre
pas question non nous allons donc
entendre les experts lambert vous pouvez
vous asseoir landais le professeur
l'honneur et d'apporter mon concours à
la justice en votre honneur et en votre
conscience je vous écoute dans le cadre
de l'instruction ouverte contre lambert
michel j'ai procédé les 26 et 27
décembre 1973 1-2 autopsie ainsi qu'à
l'examen médical mademoiselle raclet
sylvie et de l'enfant petrovic sofia
dans quel ordre voulez vous que je vous
en donne le compte-rendu monsieur le
président on peut importe commencer par
les autopsies
en ce qui concerne la mère madame
petrovic
ruzicka âgées de pardon louzy cas âgée
de 28 ans la mort a été provoquée par un
coup de feu tirés à bout touchant la
peau autour du point d'impact été brûlé
par la déflagration
la balle est entrée à la jonction du
traîneau idée du temps pour al gauche
pour ressortir par la région pariétal
droit provoquant l'éclatement de la
boîte crânienne avec projection de
matières cérébrale sur le plafond et les
murs à une distance depuis la m j'ai
également noté à la périphérie du coût
des ecchymoses et des marques permettant
de penser qu'il y avait eu une tentative
de strangulation comment expliquez vous
ces marques lambert je voulais déjà dit
elle voyait tout le temps j'ai voulu la
faire taire en essayant de l'étrangler
je penserai assez fort pour la dune
ensuite tout seul police l'enfant
petrovic on va nager les quatre ans
défenestré du neuvième étage souhaite
une chute de plus de 25 mètres le corps
était complètement disloqué que
multiples notamment du crâne et de la
colonne vertébrale avec atteinte de la
moelle épinière éclatement de la rate du
foie et rupture des vaisseaux maison
eric ce qui a provoqué une hémorragie
considérable d'enfants est mort sur le
coup
j'en viens maintenant à l'examen médical
de mademoiselle raclet sylvie 21 ans
mais c'est la jeune fille qui se
trouvait chez les petrovic au moment du
drame
un coup asséné sur somme mais dans la
vie
anne yen à déterminer une extrapolation
sanguine avec perte de connaissance
l'examen radiographique a montré
l'absence de fracture et la victime a
repris conscience si vite
mais le souvenir des faits dont elle a
été témoin indéterminée un choc émotif
violent avec épisode convulsif est allé
lucina de coire nécessitant une mise au
repos de plusieurs semaines et
l'administration de neuroleptiques
antibiotiques et et anti psychotiques
quant à la petite petrovic sofia six ans
elle souffrait d'une broncho pneumonie
sévère consécutive à son séjour prolongé
dans la forêt de montargis de nuit et
par temps très froid par ailleurs son
enlèvement et le meurtre de sa mère il
son frère est pétri sous ses yeux
avaient provoqué un état de stupeur qui
a duré plusieurs jours
enfin j'ai relevé sur le corps de
l'enfant de nombreuses traces de coups
notamment au visage aux bras et aux
cuisses c'est tout monsieur le président
de traces de coups lambert vous avez
frappé la petite fille parlait bien que
je fasse tenir tranquille et se
débattait vous les filets tout le temps
des questions mesdames et messieurs les
jurés
monsieur l'avocat général à la cour vous
remercie madame le dr dre mobile
quand j'aurai d'apporter votre concours
à la justice en votre honneur et en
votre conscience monsieur le docteur b
rieux et moi même avons examiné sur les
double plan psychiatrique et médico
psychologique
le nommé lambert michel à la prison de
fresnes où ils étaient détenus sur le
fond du caractère on note une composante
d'agressivité et un goût de la violence
certains pourtant contrairement ce que
nous rencontrons habituellement dans
pareil cas
l'enfance du sujet n'a pas été perturbé
il a été entouré par l'affection de sa
famille et a reçu une bonne éducation sa
conversation est généralement calmes
suivant un système de pensée logique et
cohérent parfois entrecoupées de courtes
bouffée de colère
lambert s'était dit lui même avec une
certaine complaisance la voie de la
délinquance dans laquelle il est engagé
très jeune correspond du muay la firme à
sa nature et à ségou il le rejette toute
forme de morale traditionnelle sans pour
autant présenter la structure
orgueilleuse du paranoïaque il n'y a eu
ni fractionnement ni dissociation de la
pensée du raisonnement tout au plus
peut-on noter légère tendance qu'ils
offraient nique
mais cette tendance ne prend à aucun
moment le caractère d'une maladie
mentale caractérisée au moment où se
sont déroulés les faits qu'on lui
reproche
lambert il n'était pas dépassé par la
situation
il a agi en pleine connaissance de cause
l'évocation de ces fêtes n'éveille
d'ailleurs aucune émotion particulière
s'il émet quelques regrets à l'alpe
l'idée d'avoir tué un enfant il en
rejette la responsabilité sur la police
dont les atermoiements son il le dit la
cause de tout
en résumé les éléments du caractère nous
tue à notre avis aucune influence sur le
comportement de lambert au moment des
fêtes
il ne relève d'aucune thérapeutique
psychiatrique et il est accessible à une
sanction pénale
mais celle-ci ne peut avoir de valeur
rééducative la réadaptation est très
aléatoire et les chances de réinsertion
sociale pratiquement nul l'oms et
messieurs les jurés avez vous des
questions à poser au docteur grémonville
non merci docteur la cour vous remercie
monsieur li faire ce qu'elles sont vos
nom prénom âge profession et domicile ni
fair michel officier de police principal
32 ans faisant élection de domicile 7
boulevard du palais à paris ivème curé
de parler sans haine et sans crainte de
dire toute la vérité rien que la vérité
lever la main droite dit je le jure je
le jure faites votre déposition machine
officier de police dans le courant du
mois de décembre 1973 j'ai appris que le
nommé lambert michel récemment libéré de
la centrale de clairvaux avait cambriolé
30 décembre nos ventres c'est ça
monsieur le président le 30 novembre ou
neuville la déserte dans le département
de l'oise
de plus sept individus s'apprêtaient à
commettre une nouvelle agression dans la
région parisienne et en informer rendez
vous auquel il devait se rendre
14 rue andré krust à villeneuve le roi
le 26 décembre vers 12 heures
j'ai pris mes dispositions pour
l'appréhender j'ai placé un collègue
dans l'appartement où il était attendu
et je suis demeuré moi-même dans
l'escalier okoye les serrer le poing de
la fuite
malheureusement lambert a réussi à nous
échapper à s'introduire par la violence
dans le logement voisin
voilà monsieur le président merci
monsieur lovisi non ne partez pas
monsieur partie des questions mesdames
et messieurs les jurés monsieur l'avocat
général m arnaud guilhem monsieur je me
perçois avec plaisir que la police ait
bien fait en france vous étiez
admirablement renseignez vous saviez que
l'on mère avait commis un cambriolage
dans l'oise saviez qu'il préparait une
nouvelle agression
comment étiez-vous au courant de tout
cela
je n'ai pas à révéler les sources
d'information sur ce d'information
qu'entendez-vous exactement par là
si ma question vous embarrassent n'y
répondez par monsieur l'officier de
police il répondait pas de toute façon
nous entendrons tout à l'heure votre
source d'information mais dites moi sans
être aussi familiariser que vous avec
les méthodes policières je m'étonne
cependant vous saviez que lombaire
préparer une agression lusage n'est-il
pas en de telles circonstances de
surveiller discrètement le suspect est
de ne l'arrêté au dernier moment la main
dans le sac si j'ose dire et autant que
possible avec ses complices
il n'y a pas de règle dans ce cas
particulier l'individu était dangereux
vous avez agi de votre propre initiative
et ion 2 mais c'est vous qui dirigeait
l'opération on aviez vous préalablement
référer à vos chefs le patron était en
congé et vous vous êtes dit que
l'arrestation de lambert serait une
bonne note pour vous qu'elle aiderait
sans doute à votre avancement
eh bien monsieur l'officier de police je
ne vous félicite pas par cette opération
mal conçu mal préparée et mal réalisée
vous avez provoqué le drame pour lequel
michel lambert est jugé aujourd'hui et
dans lequel vous porter une lourde part
de responsabilité
bravo mon silence lambert je vous
préviens que je ne tolérerai pas
incartade
je n'hésiterai pas si c'est nécessaire à
vous faire expulser ben voyons comme ça
que ce serait plus tranquille pour faire
de doute en bambina dernière fois taisez
vous merci monsieur l'officier de police
vous pouvez regagner votre service
suivant
quels sont vos nom prénom âge profession
et domicile les gens tavernay 47 ans
commissaire divisionnaire faisons
élection de domicile 7 boulevard du
palais paris 4e à l'époque de la faire
j'ai été chef de la brigade de recherche
et d'intervention aux jurés de parler
sans haine et sans crainte de dire toute
la vérité rien que la vérité devait la
main droite et dit je le jure je jure
fait votre déposition monsieur le
commissaire
le 26 décembre 1973 à l'heure du
déjeuner j'ai été averti par l'état
major qu'une agression avec prise
d'otage venait d'avoir lieu à villeneuve
le roi
je me suis aussitôt rendus sur les lieux
où mes collègues du commissariat local
et de la 11e brigade territoriale m'ont
mis au courant des faits un homme et
lambert michel s'étaient enfermés dans
un appartement du neuvième étage avec
quatre personnes qu'il retenait
prisonnière l'individu refuse à toute
discussion
il avait même tiré à travers la porte de
l'appartement pour éloigner les
policiers qui essayait de lui faire
entendre raison
je suis alors remonté au 9e étage et
j'ai tenté à mon tour d'entamer le
dialogue avec le forcené
mais il a refusé de l'écouter et exigé
le moyen d'assurer sa fuite en toute
impunité
après avoir consulté mes supérieurs
j'ai décidé de donner satisfaction à sa
demande pour ne pas mettre en danger la
vie des otages j'ai fait évacuer
l'immeuble
j'ai demandé qu'on me procure les 5
millions d'anciens francs en espèces ce
qu'ils réclamaient et j'ai fait préparer
une voiture et c'est à ce moment que
sans raison précise
lambert a battu madame p trop vite sans
raison précise et les tireurs sur le
parti ne parlait pas il n'y avait pas
des tireurs sur le sol
on fait bien que si j'avais fait placer
des observateurs il avait des jumelles
mais il n'était pas l' an der je vous le
répète je vous ordonne de vous taire
poursuivre et monsieur le commissaire
alors qu'avez vous fait après le meurtre
de madame petrovic j'ai fait ce qui me
semblait nécessaire pour que la colère
de lambert ne se déchaînent pas de
nouveau j'ai retiré mes observateurs et
les faits vacquerie évacuer les
immeubles voisins
c'est à ce moment que monsieur petrovic
que j'avais fait prévenir est arrivé je
lui ai expliqué ce qui se passait il m'a
dit qu'il allait monter entrés dans
l'appartement le lui ai défendu nous
avions à faire un fou aux réactions
imprévisibles et je n'avais pas le droit
de prendre le moindre risque
mais il m'a littéralement échappé des
mains et s'est précipité dans l'immeuble
il est monté dans l'ascenseur
j'ai aussitôt fait coupé le courant pour
qu'il ne puisse pas monter jusqu'au
neuvième étage
nous étions encore devant le disjoncteur
avec le gardien lorsque j'ai entendu des
cris à l'extérieur lambert venait de
jeter le petit garçon par la fenêtre
g
j'ai récupéré monsieur petrovic dans
l'ascenseur et nous nous sommes éloignés
pour laisser le passage libre à lambert
quelques minutes plus tard il est sorti
avec la petite fille s'est installé dans
la voiture et a pris la fuite n'avait
pas essayé de l'intercepter
il y avait déjà deux morts monsieur le
président et la petite fille était
toujours avec lui oui bien sûr les
guetteurs que vous aviez installés sur
le toit
ils étaient munis de jumelles m'avez
vous dis oui monsieur le président bon
alors est il possible que lambert est
confondu ses jumelles avec un pistolet
mitrailleur aux mitraillettes paraît
difficile de confondre daily mail
relativement petit et que l'on porte
devant les yeux avec un pistolet
mitrailleur est une arme assez
encombrante et que l'on porte un site à
quelle distance vos guetteur se
trouvait-il de la fenêtre par laquelle
lambert les a aperçus la largeur de la
rhune une vingtaine de mètres environ
cette distance en effet la confusion
paraît impossible
de plus ils avaient placé des tireurs il
aurait eu une arme de poing ou mieux un
fusil à lunette mais certainement pas un
pistolet-mitrailleur qui est une arme
précise alors autre chose maintenant
quand vous avez essayé de parlementer
avec lambert tout de suite après votre
arrivée
n'at-il pas fait allusion à anche calvi
si il m'a crié qu'il travaillait pour
quelle vie et que celui ci avait le bras
long quoi qu'il arrive affirma-t-il son
patron le couvrirait le couvrir et elle
sait ce qu'il m'a dit monsieur le
président mais c'était la pure
fanfaronnade j'ai interrogé monsieur
calvi le lendemain il m'a affirmé que
lambert n'avait jamais travaillé pour
lui et vous l'avez quoi oui monsieur le
président malgré elles ne sont pas
quel passé monsieur le président depuis
1950 à 17 reprises la police a arrêté
monsieur calvi dit cette information ont
été ouvertes contre lui qui se sont
toutes terminées par une ordonnance de
non évidemment les éléments recueillis
n'ont jamais permis de prouver sa
culpabilité
si la justice a dit à 17 reprises que
calvi était innocent pour moi monsieur
calvi est un honnête homme et je n'ai
aucune raison de mettre sa parole en
doute ces questions merci monsieur le
commissaire vous pouvez vous retire à
pardon posez vous même la question
monsieur le commissaire nous avons
relevé certains termes de votre
déposition
parlant de lambert vous avez employé le
mood forcené un peu plus tard vous avez
dit textuellement nous avions à faire un
fou je ne sais pas si lambert est fou au
sens légal du terme mais pour moi un
homme capable d'agir comme il l'a fait
nous sommes bien d'accord je je ne suis
pas psychiatre m bien sûr et en disant
que la belle a réagi dans un moment de
panique vous ne raisonnez pas en
psychiatre mais tout simplement en homme
de bon sens nous vous remercions par
d'autres questions
merci de ce commissaire monsieur mauléon
où j'ai posé votre avis
quels sont vos nom prénom âge profession
de monsieur adjudant-chef de mauléon
gilbert 43 ans commandant de la brigade
de jullouville moche aux jurés de parler
sans élan crâne de dire toute la vérité
rien que la vérité de verdun droite dit
le juge je jure vous écoutons le 18
janvier 1974 l'attention de la brigade a
été attirée par la présence d'un homme
étranger à la région qui semblait se
cacher dans une villa de la rue des
tamaris à carole plage d'une station de
vacances et à cette époque de l'année la
plupart des maisons sont inoccupés
surtout celles qui se trouvent en
bordure de plage
je suis donc allée avenue des tamaris
avec un gendarme pour interpeller
l'homme et vérifier son identité
en voyant le véhicule de la gendarmerie
s'arrêter devant la porte
il a ouvert le feu sur nous et le
gendarme vaucher a été atteint à la
cuisse
j'ai alors rendu compte par radio au
capitaine d'alsace et demander des
renforts
finalement nous avons réussi à
appréhender l'individu dans le courant
de l'après midi
non sans qu'il fasse encore usage de son
arme il a baissé grièvement le gendarme
morteau et plus légèrement une employée
communale
monsieur gandrey patrick qui se trouvait
sur la digue
après son arrestation j'ai constaté
qu'il se nommait l'envers mais chez
pierre et qui faisait l'objet d'un
mandat d'arrêt délivré par
juge d'instruction du tribunal de paris
pour la faire de villeneuve le roi
c'est tout c'est le président commençait
tout et la dérouillée by flanqué dans
votre bureau on n'en parlait pas je ne
vous ai pas touché
c'est à une douzaine un plan que du coup
de pied dans le ventre ils ont failli me
tuer le président en personne n'a frappé
lambert mais se croisent sur arles
si on nous a tellement battu lambert
pourquoi n'allez-vous pas fait constater
la trace des coûts par le juge
d'instruction qui vous entendu le soir
même et s'est arrangé ce qui est pas de
trace pas d'autres questions
mesdames et messieurs les jurés monsieur
merci monsieur l'adjudant-chef vous
pouvez regagner votre brigade
mademoiselle raclée
quels sont vos nom prénom âge profession
domicile si l'irak les 21 noms placé au
cinéma l'éden 14 rue henri cros à
villeneuve le roi aux jurés de parler
sans haine et sans crainte de dire toute
la vérité rien que la vérité
lever la main droite dit je jure
mademoiselle vous avez été mêlé de très
près aux événements du 26 décembre
oui j'habitais sur le même palier que
les petrovic c'était bizarre
ce jour là ruzic
madame petrovic était malade et j'étais
venu l'aider à faire manger les enfants
vers 1h15 il avait fini j'allais rentrer
chez moi quand j'ai ouvert la porte
quelqu'un qui était sur le palier m'a
poussé en arrière c'était lui il avait
un revolver à la main des bus avait pas
l'air vrai il était poli presque gentil
il disait que si on se tenait tranquille
tout se passe très bien
il nous a enfermés tous les quatre dans
la chambre et puis il est retourné dans
le couloir on entendait discuter à
travers la porte avec les policiers qui
étaient sur le palier tout à coup il ya
eu un coup de revolver bout d'un moment
il a rouvert la porte de la chambre et
il a dit qu'il avait faim il m'a demandé
de venir avec lui dans la cuisine
pour lui faire à sandwich j'étais pas
assurée il a mangé
il a bu de la bière et puis on y
retourner dans la chambre sic a été
terrorisée elle criait les enfants aussi
houda moment quelqu'un a appelé dans la
rue avec un porte-voix
alors il a ouvert la fenêtre pour
écouter ce qu'on lui disait on lui
disait que tout était prêt qui pouvaient
partir à ce moment là ruzicka a fait une
folie
elle a couru vers la porte alors ici
retournez il l'a vu il a rattrapé avec
son revolver à la main
c'était horrible il y avait du sang
partout
j'ai essayé de m'accrocher alors il m'a
crié de m contre le mur avec les mains
sur la tête et les enfants aussi lui
pendant ce temps là il a allumé une
cigarette comme si s'était rien passé
au bout d'un moment on a entendu le
bruit de l'ascenseur alors il s'est mis
à hurler des injures puis il a attrapé
jovan le petit à criait il s'est débattu
moi j'ai essayé de le retenir mais il
m'a donné un coup de pied je tombé par
terre
amazon
mademoiselle tout de suite avant
d'abattre madame petrovic lambert avait
aperçu un homme sur le toit d'un
immeuble de l'autre côté de la rue alors
vous même cet homme
l'avez vous vu oui monsieur le président
pendant était hilare mais non ils
avaient des jumelles si tout cas ce
qu'elle lançait l'a même pas vu son lui
a fait la leçon alors elle répète ce
qu'on lui a dit de dire ce qui pas vrai
ça sont ceux qu'elle raconte l arrange
tout à sa manière n'est ce pas pourquoi
dites vous cela lambert m'a demandé lui
pour croire qu'elle a oublié homogène
on a fait des propositions il vous
appelez des propositions à quel moment
quand on était dans la cuisine c'est pas
moi qui va des propositions celle croire
qu'un homme avec un pistolet ça
l'excitait si voyons sais pas si vous
avez demandé venant ou lambert taisez
vous mademoiselle lambert at il abusé de
vous je produisais puisque je vous dis t
elle
moi j'ai pas tellement la tête à ça
c'est moi la leur pardon ce que vous
dites est grave mademoiselle je vous
demande de bien réfléchir
vous accusez lambert de vous avoir violé
oui mais c'est moi qui raconte le viol
est un crime
vous le savez n'est ce pas alors
justement pourquoi n'avez-vous pas crier
n'a plus de papier au secours appelés
qui ruzic a été enfermé dans la chambre
vous auriez pu vous débattre essayer de
vous défendre l'avez-vous fait j'avais
peur je pensais que ça lequel murray ce
qu'il faut pas entendre
pourquoi n'avez vous rien dit à
l'instruction je voulais pas que ça se
sache
des questions mesdames et messieurs les
jurés monsieur l'avocat général merci
mademoiselle vous pouvez vous retirer
monsieur petrovic
donner à la barre
quels sont vos nom prénom âge profession
et domicile
monsieur
monsieur quels sont vos noms et prénoms
petrovic dhr admirent votre acte 28 ans
notre profession quel est votre
profession monsieur je ne travaille pas
au moment des faits vous étiez je vois
joueur de football dans l'équipe de
paris normandie
alors vous jurer de parler sans haine
sans haine et sans crainte de dire toute
la vérité rien que la vérité levé la
main droite et dit je le jure
le 26 décembre 1973
vous étiez avec votre équipe sur un
stade
quand le commissaire tavernay vous a
fait prévenir de ce qui se passait à
votre domicile
nous savons combien l'évocation de ce
drame et pénible pour vous ouvre votre
femme et votre fils ont disparu ne l'est
plus que la petite sofia neige non je
n'ai plus offrir
je le donnais un mass air je n'ai plus
rougir un prix sofia plions 20 par an
j'ai louis
qu'est ce que vous allez faire je ne
peux préjuger de la décision que
prendront la cour et le jury à l'issue
des débats
vous voulez pour moi dans la prison je
ne peux pas entrer alors j'attends je
vais lui c'est pareil
monsieur
pensez-vous avoir quelque chose à dire
qu'ils puissent aider messieurs les
jurés je pas de questions pas de
questions m la quoi vous remercie
monsieur vous pouvez vous retirer
je
il a dit qu'il n'avait aucune pudeur
lambert je regrette publicité ce
malheureux non plus épargné cette
épreuve monsieur var est ce alors tu
sais vous quels sont vos nom prénom âge
profession domicile varèse rené 46 ans
agent d'affaires 14 rue andré kraft à
villeneuve le roi
mais je me demande si votre déposition
peut être reçue sous la foi du serment
il ne tombe sur le coup d'aucune
incapacité monsieur le président j'ai
vérifié
bon alors dans ce cas où juré de parler
sans haine et sans crainte de dire toute
la vérité rien que la vérité devait la
main droite dit je le jure je dure alors
veuillez relaté à la cour les conditions
dans lesquelles vous avez fait la
connaissance de l'accusé et bien voilà
monsieur le président le 21 décembre
lambert est venu me voir de la part d'un
ami commun c'était assez confus va
parler d'une affaire et m'a demandé si
je connaissais des gens qui pourraient
l'aider je vous serai obligé de sortir
vos mains de vos poches quand vous êtes
devant la justice mme alors parlons net
monsieur varetz lambert préparait un
coup et chercher des complices tu sais
ça n'est ce pas en quelque sorte oui bon
et ben voila j'ai pas compris pourquoi
il s'adressait à moi quelqu'un avait dû
lui raconter que j'avais des relations
dans un certain milieu une relation que
bien entendu vous ne possédez pas mais
alors puisque vous ne pouviez pas lui
fournir deux complices pourquoi lui avez
vous demandé de revenir le 26 décembre
seuls silence lambert j'avais prévenu
l'officier de police me faire de ce
rendez-vous leur peau quelles raisons
leur mère m'avait parlé d'un cambriolage
qui l'avait fait le mois d'avant c'était
mon devoir d'avertir les autorités pour
your dur mais je me sens bien
je vous ordonne de vous taire lambert
quels que soient les sentiments que vous
inspire le témoin je vous interdis de
l'insulté bon je vous préviens il n'y
aura pas de nouvelles observations à la
prochaine incartade je vous fais
expulser lembeye ces questions mais
monsieur l'avocat général
oui monsieur le président a regardé ce
pistolet la barrette
c'est vous qui l'avez fournir lambert il
me semble oui quelqu'un l'avait laissé
chez moi je ne sais plus qui j'étais
bien mentalement débarrasser oui
moyennant une honnête rétribution je
présume vous avez été condamné plusieurs
fois pour recel pour escroquerie autre
délit de même nature au moment des faits
n'étiez-vous pas interdit de séjour dans
la région parisienne
en principe oui mais j'avais un père me
bats lors une tolérance tout au plus le
ministère public aurait très bien pu
vous poursuivre ce ne sont pas les
motifs qui lui auraient manqué
ainsi je vois la voix off un poisson je
suppose que la police a besoin de gens
travaux je terminais monsieur est un bon
pas de question
non monsieur le président je n'ai qu'à
remercier monsieur l'avocat général
javaux open veuillez vous retirer
monsieur k
celui-ci vous ferez entre est allé tout
de suite après oui il vaut rien quels
sont vos nom prénom âge profession
domicile callebaut ag gabriel ma mère
était très croyant
j'ai 56 ans je suis commerçant et je
demeure 57 avenue foch de paris 16e
connaissiez-vous l'accusé avant les
faits et il à votre service est vous aux
siens ou dix ans les hôtes où j'aurai de
parler sans haine et sans crainte de
dire toute la vérité rien que la vérité
devait la main droite dit je le jure je
le jure vous connaissez l'accusé depuis
longtemps une sous quelle vie au mois de
novembre 1960 et et il m'a demandé un
rendez vous par l'intermédiaire d'une
jeune femme qui travaille dans un des
établissements sortait de prison et a
justement j'avais besoin d'un livreur
je lui ai proposé le poste mais il a
refusé et nos relations sont restées là
oui pourtant je lambert n'avait-il pas
travailler pour vous à la fin 2009 161
de façon indirecte
je suis propriétaire d'un cabaret jana
qui s'occupe
il avait engagé la belle comme d'hab
mais il a laissé une dizaine de jours
square et depuis cette date n'avait
jamais directement ou indirectement
employés lambert à jamais vous n'ignorez
pas que lors de son arrestation il a dit
que vous étiez son patron que vous aviez
le bras long et qu'il était couvert par
vous
mais ça veut dire quoi couvert que
j'allais soudoyer un juge d'instruction
pour qu'il libère que j'ai fait le
pression insultant magistrats et 9 jurés
de l'accusé respecte trop la justice
tout claque de pareilles choses soient
possibles
bravo monsieur calvi vous laissez pas
faire ils essaient de vous mettre dans
le bain 15 juin mais c'est long mais
qu'est ce vous avez abattu cette jeune
femme et son bébé et personne ne partage
les responsabilités avec vous messieurs
les jurés des questions monsieur
l'avocat général oui monsieur le
président quelle vie de pardon monsieur
calvi au cours des mois de novembre et
de décembre 1973 lambert ne faisait pas
partie
c'est vrai du personnel de vaud dujon de
vos différentes entreprises commerciales
non mais vous auriez pu l'engager
cependant comme garde du corps par
exemple ou comme homme de main non voilà
que ça recommence
pendant des années monsieur le président
la police me persécute et m'accusait de
vol de proxénétisme
de fortis car lé discours que l'idée
chantage dit enfin par la grâce de dieu
à chaque fois j'ai pu prouver mon
innocence et 17 fois la justice a dit
que je n'étais pas coupable j'espérais
que mon nom était celui concernant connu
non monsieur l'avocat général on n'en
n'est ni gardes du corps nyomi mais je
suis pas bandits mais supposons suppose
années sans qu'il soit vrai 17 non lieu
ça veut dire quelque chose non cela
supposait une baballe certaine
intelligence une certaine habileté dans
le choix de mes collaborateurs croyez
vous que je l'engagé un garçon comme ça
pourquoi n'auriez-vous pas engagé mais
parce que c'est un malade doit il a fait
le jeu de ses combien de séjour en
prison à chaque fois qu'il était sur un
point il se fait pas et puis je vous
dire autre chose
il ya ici quelqu'un qui me connaît bien
et qui ne me contredira pas c'est mon
vieil adversaire et ami le commissaire
tarn et je n'ai jamais tué ni jamais
fait tu es innocent comme cette
malheureuse hugo slave son bébé ou le
gardien donner un accès en 1962 il était
ligoté sur une chaise quand votre bilan
belle et l'a défendue par derrière une
balle dans la nuque alors s'annonce
l'admettra pourquoi vous parler de ça
alors ni toujours encore des poulets
êtres humains
non je n'y avait pas d'argent et d'armes
non mascara j'ordonne comme je suis
rendu de l'audience
mais conformément aux articles 320 à 3
122 du code de procédure criminelle sur
pénal l'accusé sera gardé par la force
publique jusqu'à la fin des débats à la
disposition de la cour
après chaque audience mais qui lui sera
donnée par monsieur le greffier du
procès verbal des débats alors maître
arnaud guilhem je pense que vous avez
des questions à poser aux témoins ce
président le témoin s'il faut l'en
croire est un ardent défenseur de
l'ordre et de la morale publique
son mérite est d'autant plus grand qu'il
règne sur un empire quelque peu frelaté
de cabaret et de boîtes de nuit et je
m'incline devant cet homme de bien
votre souci de justice monsieur vous
conduit également à vous intéresser au
sort des détenus mois venant pourquoi eh
bien depuis son incarcération en janvier
74 vous avait expédié à lambert un deux
trois quatre cinq six mandats chacun
d'eux représentant une somme élevée
je ne la laverai du taux en voici les
talons expéditeurs ange calvi
expéditeurs ange calvet mort
oui mais ce n'est pas moi qui les ai
envoyées
curieux quelqu'un ce serait dans servi
de votre nom il est vrai que ne
connaissant pas lambert vous n'aviez
aucune raison de lui expédier de
l'argent pour pour acheter son silence
par exemple pour qu'il affirme n'avoir
jamais travaillé pour vous lambert ne
travaillait pas pour moi et je ne lui ai
pas envoyer d'argent à point c'est tout
pas d'autres questions
la cour vous remercie vous pouvez aller
parler
même qu'il est gaucher
quels sont vos noms prénoms et âges
ballet louis 62 ans trouvait
actuellement sous le régime de la
détention provisoire en attendant d'être
jugés pour des délits nous n'avons pas à
connaître mais vous avez antérieurement
des condamnés à des peines criminelles
et vous êtes frappés de dégradation
civique ce qui vous interdit de déposer
sous la foi du serment vous entendre on
à titre de simples renseignements m
arnaud guilhem ce témoin a été cité à
votre requête alors je vous laisse le
soin de lui poser vos questions merci
monsieur le président vous avez été
détenu à clairvaux en même temps que
lambert braille comment on a été pendant
presqu'un an dans la même cellule en
europe ans et si on se connaissait bien
répondez à l'accusé s'est elle excusée
mais c'est la première fois que je me
trouve là parce que la dernière fois
jetés mais jamais un autre président un
gros arbre une fille ce que vous
connaissez bien lambert parlez nous de
lui
post1 bon tu produis tout genre km
au début je me méfiais un peu on est
devenus copains quand j'avais pas de
pognon pour cantiner partager avec moi
on voit pas ça tous les jours
c'était vraiment un ami et il y arrive
et il d'être puni habits étaient
présentes dur c'est déjà pas si mal non
non je veux dire durant sa détention à
clairvaux allant jamais il était peinard
ne mouftait pas poli avec les maths on
est tous et vous souvenez vous d'un
incident qui s'est produit en juillet 73
et comment il va essayer de se suicider
dans une autre division un type qu'on
connaissait pas à l'affirmer il était au
centre où ils ont demandé des donneurs
de sang et bat lambert s'est porté
volontaire vous rendez compte donner son
sang un type qu'on n'a jamais vus
fallait le faire
jugez vous même monsieur le président
c'est ce que je m'efforce de faire avec
mesdames et messieurs les jurés naturel
merci alors des questions
monsieur l'avocat général oui monsieur
le président pas l'air vous avez été
libéré de clairvaux en même temps que
lambert le semaine d'après oui vous vous
êtes installé à paris vous aussi oui
monsieur le paquet vous l'avez revue de
trois fois il avait commis un
cambriolage il se préparait à attaquer
une banque ne vous at il pas demandé
d'être son complice si ça ne vous at-il
pas étonné répondait ainsi à un peu
pourquoi
là il m'a dit qu'il travaillait pour
ange calvi je vois pas pourquoi ils
avaient besoin de chercher des étrangers
vous avez accepté sa proposition
non là aussi pourquoi oh c'est pas des
coûts pour moi ça c'était trop risqué
j'ai plus l'âge nananan par depardon
permettait au cours de l'information
vous avez donné une autre explication
est beaucoup plus vraisemblable celle là
vous avez déclaré je ne voulais pas
travailler avec lui on m'avait prévenu
que c'était un type dangereux qu'il
avait la détente facile en 62 à
marseille il avait descendu un gardien
de nuit et on savait qu'il
recommencerait à la première occasion
voilà la vérité en somme même dans le
milieu
lambert est considéré comme un
personnage dangereux qu'il vaut mieux ne
pas fréquenter
c'est tout monsieur le positif par
d'autres questions garde vous pouvez
emmener le détenu à noizay dubray
compris quels sont vos nom prénom âge
profession et domicile
j'alignerai 27 ans hôtesse 31e michel
paris 9ème tour et de parler sans haine
et sans crainte de dire toute la vérité
rien que la vérité lever la main droite
dit je le jure qu'elle gier maître
arnaud willay clp cité ce témoin s'est
pas évadé quand même mademoiselle vous
êtes hôtesse dans un cabaret ouais le
corsaire noir place pigalle qui est le
propriétaire de cet établissement
mission jusqu'à lui michel lambert ne
vous at il jamais demandé de lui obtenir
un rendez vous avec monsieur calvi bah
si c'est au début si on se qualifie il
m'a dit qu'ils viennent le voir le
lendemain soir et comment s'est déroulé
leurs conversations au beau ça je sais
pas mais j'ai eu l'impression que michel
était content et qu'il ait obtenu ce
qu'ils voulaient quoi lambert at il revu
monsieur calvi après ce rendez vous
ouais sûrement michel y tenait presque
tous les soirs en corsaire noir puis
monsieur calvi il était souvent là non
mademoiselle vous avez vécu avec lambert
pendant près de deux mois
ouais ouais il est arrivé début novembre
tout est à peu de clairvaux il n'est de
la part d'un copain ils savaient pas où
loger
il tenait ces personnes à paris et puis
vous savez quand ils sortent de prison
et il pense tous à la même chose surtout
plus ils avaient fait plus de 11 ans
alors bon mais michel il était pas comme
les autres il était gentil avec lui on
pouvait causer
vous avez un enfant je crois ouais j'ai
un petit garçon tellement avec le métier
que je fais je prends le temps de m'en
occuper
alors je vis chez ma cousine normandie
michel il est il est venu deux ou trois
fois le voir avec moi c'est derrière
mais ça fait plaisir
l'avocat général oui j'ai là quelques
fiches de police qui concerne notre
témoin je vois racolage sur la voie
publique
attitude de nature à provoquer la
débauche outrage public à la pudeur je
constate candeur de votre profession de
commandes hôtesse vous êtes une personne
très occupé non rassurez-vous la
prostitution n'étant pas un délit je ne
reproche rien mais dites-moi ses
activités comment dirais-je annexes
doivent vous procurer des revenus
appréciables
ça dépend des clients et vous remettiez
alembert une partie de vos gains ouais
c'est normal à ces normes
ap lambert est donc également proxénète
une qualité de plus à son actif si j'ose
m'exprimer ainsi je vous remercie on
n'osait pas d'autres questions
avez vous envoyé de l'argent à lambert
pendant son séjour en prison
oui ah ah non ah non je me souviens plus
très bien maintenant ça s'est bien fait
un petit effort de mémoire mademoiselle
parce que je vous rappelle que vous
déposer sous serment
avez vous envoyé des mandats à lambert
ouais
sous votre propre nom bah oui bien sûr
n'avez-vous pas indiqué plus tôt celui
de monsieur ange calvillo et pourquoi
j'aurais fait ça c'est pas moi mais je
pense que les revenus que procure la
prostitution ne figure pas j'imagine sur
vos déclarations de fin d'année alors
l'envoi de ses mandats importants
auraient pu attirer sur vous la tension
indiscrètes du fisc idiot pas d'autres
questions la cour merci mademoiselle
le sur le chef des gardes voulez vous
faire revenir lambert pris envers le
ministère public va prendre ses
réquisitions
dès votre avocat va présenter votre
défense il me semble souhaitable que
vous soyez présent la condition que vous
ne criez pas un nouvel incident j'en ai
rien à [ __ ] façon je dirai plus rien
ce prix à peine à poser de questions
vous plaignez de la justice mais vous ne
faites rien pour qu'elle suive son cours
normal
essayez-vous jeu l'avocat général vous
avez la parole pour vos réquisitions
de mort quatre blessés dont un
grièvement atteint
une petite fille traumatisée pour la vie
un homme brisé à tout jamais tel sens
monsieur le président madame et monsieur
de la cour
mesdames et messieurs les jurés ce qui
se dresse devant vous ce soir pour
demander justice plutôt que de revenir
sur des faits abondamment prouvé et que
l'accusé d'ailleurs reconnaît je vais
essayer de de cerner sa personnalité
je vais essayer de comprendre pour le
moment je voulais vous je ne parviens
pas qui est michel lambert il ya vingt
ans la réponse ut5 un garçon de bonne
famille élevé dans un foyer uni par des
parents affectueux mais c'était il ya
vingt ans depuis
depuis un camarade mal choisi un premier
faux pas puis des actes de plus en plus
graves
sanctionnés par des peines de plus en
plus lourdes
les occasions de s'amender ne lui ont
pourtant pas manqué il les a toutes
refusées toujours volontairement il a
fermé la porte à tout espoir à chacun de
ses moments de liberté
il s'enfonce un peu plus dans le crime
est dans l'europe jusqu'à la tuerie
jusqu à l'affreuse du riz de villeneuve
le roi
lambert appartient à cette génération de
malfaiteurs pour lesquels la vie humaine
un compte pas on est armés anti sans
provocation sans raisonnement nous la
vie humaine ne compte pas la vie des
autres tout au moins la sienne
il y tient il la défend mais ils la
défendent à maintenir des larges vers
lambert est un lâche ils plastronnent il
fanfaronne il joue les durs les caïds
mais c'est une façade
c'est un faux semblant est il plus
grande lâcheté que de prendre des otages
pour assurer sa fuite que de tuer une
femme que de tuer un enfant
un enfant et de quelle horrible faso en
le jetant par la fenêtre de la touche au
papier lâcheté encore que d'inventer
après coup et au mépris de toute
vraisemblance la mauvaise excuse d'un
tireur armé d'une mitraillette lâcheté
aussi que de se retrancher derrière un
prétendu patrons aux ordres duquel on
obéit règlement où je n'ai pas prendre
en considération pour ce monsieur comme
à gan vie malgré ses 17 non lieu et je
ne suis pas sûr que sa déposition à
cette barre est était le reflet de
l'exacte vérité tout au moins en ce qui
concerne ses propres activités qu'un
pour son jugement sur lambert il a dit
vrai il la définit une phrase une phrase
terrible
vous étiez seul quand vous avez abattu
cette jeune femme et son bébé personne
n'en partagent la responsabilité avec
vous et bien non lambert personne n'a
partagent la responsabilité avec vous
cette responsabilité que vous avez
toujours tenté d'esquiver et je n'oublie
pas en ce moment le détenu
mystérieusement assassinés dans la cour
d'une prison vous avez bénéficié de la
libye douteux que vous ont fourni vos
camarades de cellule
la loi du milieu a joué en votre faveur
et la loi tout court a été bafouée mer
il y à plus grave encore la gratuité et
je dis bien m la gratuité de tous ces
meurtres
lambert n'avait pas besoin de jalonner
sa route de cadavre pas plus celui du
gardien battu il ya quinze ans par
derrière alors qu'il était sans défense
que celui de madame petrovic ou celui du
petit yoann il l'a dit lui même temps
que cette petite fille était avec moi je
ne risquais rien alors pourquoi pourquoi
va appeler la mère et son petit garçon
pourquoi pourquoi je vais vous le dire
pour le plaisir de tuer je sais je sais
combien ces deux mots plaisir et et se
heurtent je n'hésite pourtant pas les
employés ensemble à lézat tollé car je
suis bien obligé de constater cette
vérité cette vérité à trans lambert n
tuer mais alors me direz-vous c'est un
c'est un malade c'est un fou non non les
experts psychiatres ont été formels et
dieu sait si ce n'est pas toujours le
tas et pour lambert leur assurance est
entière
ils n'étaient pas dépassé par les
événements il agit en pleine
connaissance de cause sa responsabilité
est totale
donc ce n'est pas un dément que vous
jugez aujourd'hui mais un être lucide un
être conscient et je le répète un est
responsable
mesdames et messieurs les jurés comme
vous avec la même attention de chaque
instant j'ai suivi les débats j'ai
attendu comme bull
la phrase le mot qui nous permettrait
aux ne disons pas de comprend lambert
mais tout au moins d'entrevoir une une
explication de 200 tirs de deviner
quelque chose qui viendrait atténuer si
peu que ce soit le poids de son crime
jusqu'à son dernier retour dans cette
salle pendant quelques minutes j'ai
attendu en vain il n'y a pas une fleur
dans ce cauchemar
j'ai espéré passionnément je n'ai pas
trouvé la moindre circonstance
atténuante pas une seule fois on a senti
en lui l'ombre d'un remords d'un simple
regret pas l'ombre d'un sentiment humain
lambert n'est plus un homme il s'est mis
lui même au ban de l'humanité
que vous dire de plus
votre jugement servira d'exemple à tous
ceux qui espèrent s'engager sans risque
dans la voie du crime que si vous lui
permettez un jour même lointain de
retrouver la liberté
il recommencera comment 62 comment 73 et
peut-être même pire encore tout ça
malheureusement vous le savez et c'est
pourquoi si dur que vous en soit la
décision vous appliquerez la loi dans
toute sa rigueur
pour la première fois de ma longue
carrière et je le souhaite de tout mon
coeur pour la dernière aussi je vous
demande
mesdames et messieurs les jurés
de refuser l'accusé le bénéfice des
circonstances atténuantes
je requiers contre lambert la peine de
mort
la parole est à la défense
monsieur le président madame et monsieur
de la cour
mesdames et messieurs les jurés
je suis bouleversé non par la sévérité
du ministère public je l'attendais mais
par la haine que j'ai senti tout au long
de l'audience la haine d'une société qui
a peur qui crient vengeance qui hurlent
avec les loups
et bien moi je vous demande et je suis
convaincu que c'est possible je vous
demande de comprendre michel lambert
lambert le fils de bonne famille devenue
lambert le dévoyer oui il est attiré par
la délinquance c'est vrai ils rejettent
la morale conventionnelle c'est vrai
aussi
j'ai eu la curiosité d'en chercher la
raison et je me suis penché sur une
partie importante de sa vie qu une
enquête de police bak cléa pratiquement
escamoté on ne nous a rien dit de son
adolescence et c'est regrettable car
vous auriez appris entre 12 et 17 ans
michel lambert était un enfant mal
portant un asthme saisonniers l'empêcher
de courir de se mêler au jeu de ses
camarades il rêvait à cette époque comme
tous les garçons de son âge de faire
partie d'une bande
un de ces groupes d'adolescents qui
complotent dans le coin d'une cour de
lycée qui se battent entre eux pour pour
le sourire d'une fille mais les bandes
ne voulait pas de lui on écarter
l'asthmatique toujours à la traîne et
lambert demeuré seul dans son coin
solitaire rejeté par les autres il est
resté au sortir de l'adolescence quand
un instinct pervers oui pervers je n'ai
pas peur d'employer le mot quand on est
un pervers la pousser vers la
délinquance
il a rencontré le même refus le milieu
la rejeter
on ne voulait pas trop court
de ce fils de famille ce garçon qui a
reçu une bonne éducation
vous l'avez entendu s'exprimer avec des
mots qui sonnent faux dans un argot
fabriquer malhabile alors alors il a
fait de lui-même une caricature de
mauvais garçons parce que les
authentiques mauvais garçon ne voulait
pas de lui
calvi par exemple j'ai l'absolue
conviction qu'il a travaillé pour lui eh
bien vous avez entendu avec quel mépris
hautain calvi s'est adressé à lui
lambert ne fait pas partie de son monde
la pègre leur unique il n'est pas du
même sens et c'est pour cela parce qu'on
le refuse et qu'il est allé si loin pour
prouver à ces truands auquel il voue
l'été ensemble et qu'il était digne de
pour relever le défi pour montrer ce
qu'il était capable de faire
dès lors c'est l engrenage le crime la
prison le crime de nouveau parce qu'on
n'a pas le choix et pas des meurtres
gratuits commis pour le plaisir
non monsieur l'avocat général je les dis
et je le répète en tueur madame petrovic
et son fils michel lambert et fonder sa
liberté n'oubliez pas qu'il était cerné
par la police se laisser arrêter alors
qu'il était recherché pour un
cambriolage
cela signifiait 8 10 ans de prison et il
faut il faut avoir approché comme je le
fais quotidiennement ces hommes qui ont
passé de longues années en prison pour
connaître leur terreur à l'idée d'y
retourner 10 trous pire durant des mois
des années que l'on parvient même plus à
compter dont ils sont sans espoir
ne vous méprenez pas ces meurtres sont
abominables comme vous ils me révolte
et je ne cherche pas les excuses et je
voudrais justement vous faire comprendre
que dans l'esprit dérangé de cet homme
il c'était inéluctable
il a eu tort mille fois tu mais il
obéissait à une force obscure
irrésistible
les psychiatres n'ont pas été aussi
formel qu'on a bien voulu le faire
croire
ils ont noté chez lambert une tendance
schizophrénique une tendance à faire le
mal contre laquelle il ne pouvait lutter
il ne faut pas l'oublier vous devez
tenir compte de cet instinct profond
impérieux certes lambert n'est pas un
dément dans le sens précis que le code
donne à cette terne mais mais il n'est
pas non plus un homme normal et vous
l'avez bien vu ses sarcasmes
cette ironie les incidents qu'il a
créées jusqu'à rendre son expulsion
nécessaire alors qu'il était devant vous
ces juges qui tenait sa liberté et sa
vie entre vos mains
croyez vous qu'un homme totalement sain
d'esprit aurait agi ainsi
évidemment non il se serait bien tenu il
n'aurait pas élevé la voix il aurait
essayé de faire bonne impression mais
lambert n'est pas un homme totalement
sain d'esprit
bien sûr il faut le punir durement
sévèrement mais vous ne vous laisserez
pas guidé par cette haine par cet
instinct primaire de la vengeance qu'a
exprimé le ministère public vous
n'appliqueraient pas la vieille loi
cruel du talion vous n'avez pas le droit
il y a deux hommes dans lambert le
criminel dont on a parlé tout au long de
cette audience mais aussi celui qui va
avec mademoiselle libre et visiter son
enfant celui qui partage son bien avec
des compagnons déshérités pour qu'ils
aient droit eux aussi à la cantine celui
qui donne spontanément son sang pour
sauver un inconnu
et cet homme là
aussi petit soit il a le droit de vivre
tout homme a le droit de vivre
la phrase qu'a prononcé monsieur
l'avocat général
je requiers la peine de mort contre
michel lambert on ne l'avait pas entendu
depuis longtemps dans ce prétoire et
j'espérais que plus jamais on ne
l'entendrait cette peine de mort que
bien des pays parfois moins évoluée que
le nôtre on abolit temps elle leur
semble déshonorante cet héritage d'une
époque où la justice n'avait d'autre
ambition que de punir sans même essayer
de comprendre
allez vous à votre tour l'appliquer et
vous tuer un homme
allez vous l'envoyez à l'échafaud
allez-vous lui trancher la tête
on reproche à lambert de n'avoir pas
compris que la vie humaine est sacrée
que nul n'a le droit de la détruire la
société que vous représentez ne peut pas
commettre la même monstrueuse erreur
accusés avez vous quelque chose à
ajouter pour votre défense
des débats sont terminés j'ordonne que
le dossier de la procédure à l'exception
de l'arrêt de renvoi soit déposé entre
les mains de monsieur greffiers des
questions posées en conforme à l'arrêt
de renvoi nous en considérons la lecture
comme fait alors mesdames et messieurs
les jurés avant que nous nous retirions
pour délibérer je vais vous donner
lecture de l'instruction suivante
la loi ne demande pas compte aux juges
des moyens par lesquels se sont
convaincus elle ne leur prescrit pas de
règle dès qu'elles doivent faire
particulièrement dépendre la plénitude
ou la suffisance d'une preuve leur
prescrit de s'interroger romaine dans le
silence et dans le recueillement et de
chercher dans la sincérité de leur
conscience
quelle impression faite sur leur raison
l'épreuve rapporté contre l'accusé ait
les moyens de sa défense
la loi leur fait que cette seule
question qui renferme toute la mesure de
leur devoir
avez vous une intime conviction
j'invite le chef du service d'ordre a
fait regarder les issues de la salle de
délibération dans laquelle nul ne pourra
pénétrer pour quelque cause que ce soit
sans mon autorisation
mesdames et messieurs les jurés veuillez
vous rendre dans la chambre du conseil
pour y délibéré avec la cour ne pourront
sortir qu'après avoir pris une autre
décision garde fait retirer l'accusé
l'auditoire
l'audience est suspendue
mesdames et messieurs les jurés ne voici
donc réunis pour décider du sort de
lambert je vous rappelle il vient de
comparaître devant notre cour d'assises
pour répondre du meurtre de madame
petrovic du meurtre du petit diovan
petrovic la séquestration de
mademoiselle sylvie raclée et de la
petite sofia
petrovic ainsi que des violences qui
leur a fait subir et en outre d'une
triple tentative d'homicide volontaire
car lors de son arrestation il a blessé
trois personnes dont deux gendarmes
ce qui le rend passible de la peine de
mort alors la décision que nous
prendrons je vous le rappelle est
absolument irrévocable
il n'y a pas d'appel en matière
criminelle mais je pense qu'il serait
utile de même que nous échangions que
vous échangez quelques points de vue et
que vous nous expose y est votre opinion
sur des débats que vous venez d'assister
quel est votre jugement je vais demander
par ordre d'abord à monsieur le premier
jury élit son sens premier abord lambert
semble être née réductible évidemment la
sphère de choisy-le-roi une map le roi
vignoble d'importance l'ess s'est posé
beaucoup de choses
lesquels lesquels c'est que somme toute
il était
étaient poursuivis mais en réalité on
aurait pu attendre avant de le cerner
parce que tout le drame et da sur cette
affaire là associés tels devoir de se
protéger mais pas de provoquer madame
pour moi michel lambert est un criminel
responsable
pour l'instant vous expliciter pas votre
opinion moi je crois que la police est
intervenue beaucoup trop tôt qui a
déclenché toute la prise d'otage dont il
est coupable mais pas à ses avants qui
aurait fallu essayer de le récupérer
lambert pensez vous qu'on puisse le
récupérer
enfin oui et non oui dans on devrait y
arriver
est ce qu'il est ce qu'il ya quelqu'un
qui essayait de l'aider
notre monsieur nous avons tous eu dans
notre vie à prendre une responsabilité
n'avait certainement rien de comparable
avec celle que vous ne parliez de
prendre aujourd'hui lorsque ça m'est
arrivé je crois que j'ai toujours fait
preuve de énormément de clémence mais là
devant les faits reprochés à michel
lambert je crois que le maurer prend
vraiment sa véritable signification
je pense que la peine maximum peut lui
être infligée il la méritait si j'ose
dire
qui est beaucoup plus heureux en prison
quand liberté parce qu'il est encadré
bien besoin de ça mais vous envisagez le
bonheur de la cuisine ou non pas une
sanction pénale
qu'est ce que vous pensez de la terre
non moi je pense qu'on a pas le droit de
tuer quelqu'un c'est une position figure
évident pour moi il est récupérable
ils les récupèrent irrécupérable
récidiviste dans et puis alors il est
issu de sang froid des enfants un type
qui est sans défense comme ça a été dit
ou les plus d'une balle dans la nuque
même pas en passe alors c'est déjà un
l'âge de ce côté là madame madame
petrovic est morte il ya eu un enfant de
mort c'est une chose horrible moi je
reprendrai votre mot c'est horrible mais
comment un être humain peut-il est amené
à faire quelque chose d'horrible comme
ça on l'a mis en prison on l'a libéré
est ce qu'on s'était occupé de lui quand
il est sorti de prison la deuxième fois
lorsqu'il a fait ses quatre ans de
détention qu'est ce qu'il est devenu
je crois qu'un homme qui sort de prison
l'a pas d'autre solution que d'aller
retrouver les gens qu'il a connus en
prison
il n'y a aucune n'a pu rien il n'a plus
d'amis n'a plus de relation ceci dit et
ce qui s'est passé est horrible
je ne veux pas encore donné de pillon
définitive
j'avoue que j'attends la discussion
comme les pignons n'est pas encore fait
moi je considère que monsieur lambert
n'a pas beaucoup de circonstances
atténuantes parce que il a commis
froidement ces crimes
si la loi
était assez sévère c'est à dire que si
au moment où on est venu l'arrêter s'il
était certain que entre se laisser
arrêter
ils avaient le choix entre se laisser
arrêter et faire quelques années de
prison ou alors essayé d'assassiner
cetera et risqué donc la peine de mort
s'ils avaient à ce moment là la
certitude que c'était la peine de mort
est libre et sans doute choisi
puisqu'ils tiennent beaucoup à la vie il
aurait choisi certainement la première
solution
madame de ce conte assesseurs je pense
que l'envers
veut il a une volonté déterminée de
s'affirmer dans le milieu du crime et
qu'il y aura de plus en plus loin
d'autre part les experts ont rarement
été aussi catégorique en disant qu'il
était absolument pas récupérable pour ce
qui est de la défense en prenant des
otages
là aussi les deux que les deux premiers
crimes étaient gratuits puisque il a
gardé la petite fille il savait très
bien qu'en gardant la petite fille la
police ne ferait rien agir et pas alors
c'est vraiment de crime gratuit
je pars je te fais le pineau du deuxième
ses soeurs il faut garder à l'esprit que
cet homme est dangereux parce que parce
qu'il est eu naturellement ils tuent
facilement et 2 qui sera sorti de prison
s'il en sort il recommencera je viens
d'annoncer trop facilement
elle prend facilement les psychiatres
peuvent se tromper parce que c'est
anormal pour un homme normal seuls deux
clubs russes avant l'enterrement
monsieur mais quand tu es tu il a peur
aussi
donc c'est pas normal qu'avec oms avait
peur comme ça c'est pour ça que tu sais
qu'il a peur de la vapeur j'avais peur
et puis j'adore
en fait pour défendre bien par l alerte
incendie
la vie des autres sacres et cetera pour
lui sa vie la sienne est sacré est la
sienne que sa crise des autres je ne
suis pas d'accord parce que moi je crois
que sa vie soit sacré pour lui pas dans
de tels risques qui doit bien s'attendre
j'aurais pu aussi de l'incroyable
conscient lorsque vous trouvez conscient
madame mes chutes je suis d'accord
je dis pas qu'il soit fou n'est pas fou
mais est inconscient pis il savait si sa
vie n'était pas sacré vous dites avis
n'est pas sacré au lieu de tuer le gosse
il avait qu'à sauter par la fenêtre au
lieu de le jeter par l'arménie huile
quand même à savli mais pas un militant
de risque qui sait qu'un jour ça peut
lui arriver aussi
mais il y pense et il pense pas à lui
c'est sa vie qui dépend seulement salim
aggar oms a vu un clan des autres
oui alors moi j'ai la poisse et arrêtez
pas touche à la fois madame il n'a
aucune notion du respect de la vie
m total de la notion du respect de la
vie
mais vous lui apprit madame à leur
mérite en algérie la presse a facilement
on lui avait enseigné tout est possible
donc s'il est un peu simple d'esprit
lagarde et non humaine certes il n'a
jamais vue de mener une vie normale on
dort pendant ta tous à la fin
monsieur en fait il n'a jamais mené une
vie normale en dehors de la prison il
n'est jamais resté deux ou trois mois
sans commettre une agression ou un vol
il a mal démarré pour lui la vie c'est
simple il semblait tout de même avoir un
problème qui était celui là à affirmer
sa personnalité
c'est horrible mais il ya des gens qui
préfèrent faire quelque chose aurait
pour voir leur nom dans les journaux
peut-être s'il avait eu l'occasion dans
leur vie d'avoir leur nom dans le
journal en faisant en ayant une grande
situation en faisant un acte d'héroïsme
il aurait peut-être aussi nié la
première fois il est récent
un journal à la une de l'actualité
et s ils avaient vraiment voulu voir son
nom dans le journal et sera laissée
prend dix seraient rendus c'était
suffisant il en avait assez fait pour
avoir son heure
sinon à la première page du moins dans
le journal lui-même sa photo dans le
journal ou mamies se serait jetée du
neuvième étage elle est étonnée de ce
que je vais vous dire après le vent
était je crois peu près le seul à
prendre une position claire nette
précise quand je dois dire je suis
catholique et qu'en effet on ne doit pas
disposer de la vie d'autrui
mais je trouve et c'est surtout lorsque
monsieur petrovic vient à la barre la
seule réflexion que fait lambert il est
dingue ce mec il a tué sa femme il a tué
sa fille devant l'autre enfant et il est
dingue le mec aucun remord rien n'ont
pas de pitié aucune
c'est une bête sauvage des demandes est
dangereux quand on parle de bêtes
dangereuses il ya deux solutions ou bien
on n'a pas une bête dangereuse ou bien
on l'a mais quelque part on se demande
en essayant de la de lui donner un peu
de douceur la remette la libérer il n'en
est pas question elle est dangereuse
là je suis tout à fait d'accord mais est
ce qu'on a le droit d'abattre quelqu'un
qui est un être humain qui n'est pas une
bête qui est un être humain dangereux
mais un être humain tout de même alors
est-ce qu'on ne peut pas s qui n'existe
pas il n'existe pas deux états de
réclusion à vie si on le condamne à la
réclusion à vie par le jeu des
réductions de peine dans un certain
nombre d'années sortent il sortira
sortira je devrais de mardan yamada je
voudrais demander à madame qui a fait
comparaison
l'animal et l'humain si elle a fait
cette comparaison au bénéfice de
l'humain et de l'animal
lorsqu'un petit grain s'échappe de sa
cage qu'il détruit ou qu'il tube qui
dévore âme ses gardiens que fait on
l'abat jour c'est un tigre parce que
c'est un tigre et que jusqu'à maintenant
on n'a pas pu prouver mais le tigre et
nsu elle avait tout de même été conçu de
cette façon là qu'il fallait il faut
qu'ils se nourrissent de ces pas ses
propres moyens
c'était quand même pas le cas de lambert
mais ce n'est pas comparable
non donc quand vous comparez l'animal et
l'humain dans ce cas là l'animal est
bien meilleure qu'à lui ment ou
d'anciens hippies
oui mais justement il est anormal qu'un
être humain devienne comme ça il s'est
passé quelque chose
alors tout le monde doit bénéficier de
circonstances atténuantes je ne peux
plus rien faire et à plus de justice
possible
il peut avoir cinq minutes de mauvais
passage alors il faut s qu'il faut aussi
empêché 1 1 il faut empêcher un homme de
nuire à la société
ça c'est une façon de raisonner et puis
parallèlement il faut aussi penser à cet
homme là on peut pas le supprimer en
disant il vaut rien il est pas bon pour
la société on le supprime point final
c'est par réseau des produits non mais
même à ce moment là c'est toute la
société qui en cause au départ au départ
à cause de sa première peine
bon il reste donc des expertises tout
alors il aurait dû quand même voir un
peu le gore et quand il était donc en
prison
il aurait dû laisser dehors faire son
éducation est tous un peu le goff
essayer de voir c'est notre problème de
réfléchir un peu voilà je vais réfléchir
parce que d'elle à 40 ans pour les
enfants vin va sortir il est récupérable
je suis un bon monsieur
le second est madame gauche et
regrettent tous les deux une lacune du
système pénitentiaire
je pensais que nous nous restons nous
les premiers c'est que le juge
d'application des peines n'est pas à
chaque fois derrière lui une cohorte des
six stands social pour ceux qui paie
individuellement de la chaque condamné
et à l'intérieur de la prison pour le
risque et bien sûr la sauvegarde ou
nager sera les premiers alors c'est une
question de crédit alors ceci étant dit
le problème puisque ça n'existe pas si
on faisait le procès de lambert avant le
meurtre
ce serait bien différent à ce moment là
bien sûr on pourrait mettre en cause les
uns et les autres marais etc
mais c'est le procès de l'envers à cause
du meurtre et le meurtre personne lu la
dictée personne lui a dit de faire ce
coup là là il a fait pour défendre sa
peau uniquement et défendre sa peau même
pas sa peau de la de l'échafaud parce
qu'il était sûr de pas l'avoir mais
défendre sa peau de onze ans de prison
contre onze ans de prison il a tué deux
enfants puisque vous avez dit l'isf est
revenue à peu près enfin un enfant et sa
mère
monsieur casanova a parlé de moi j'ai
l'impression il ya des personnages dont
lambert ce personnage et tout a changé
pendant quelques minutes quelques
instants c'est d'être géniaux les
experts l'ont dit un homme normal mais
avec des moments d'égarement et de viol
émises à justifier la haine à chaque
instant colère de couleurs
je pense que tout le monde a des moments
de colère et si nous devions tous tués
dans les moments de colère les
cimetières serait plaint donc
massivement répondre aux arguments de
madame qui disait que justement on
devrait empêcher ce genre d'individus
dangereux de nuire à la société
vous avez mentionné justement les
possibilités donc de de créer un
meilleur climat social de l'aider autant
que possible que l'éducation soit très
bonne que l'environnement soit excellent
etc
mais moi je suis convaincu que ça ne
pourra jamais suffire pour la simple
raison que ces tendances agressives nous
les avons tous pratiquement à des degrés
très divers et que le rôle de la justice
justement et de d'empêcher que ces
tendances agressives une se développent
dans des chemins dangereux pour la
société
donc il faut que la justice essaye de
l'en somme de réfréner de dissuader les
personnes qui ont des tendances de ce
genre mais je suis tout à fait d'accord
mais tu es un homme autrement pense
jamais jamais dissuader ceux qui ont
entre les mêmes tendances mais qui sont
sur le point de commettre les mêmes
crimes
en fait il faut avoir une force de
dissuasion suffisante d'un côté et
ensuite de notre sens bien sûr canaliser
ces tendances agressives vers d'autres
voies moins nocif pour la société des
forêts du siècle majorité de la peine et
oui exactement
mais le problème d'être débattue écoute
rezé et pourquoi pas parce que j'étais
dans l'exemple ici l'exemple et
hippiques
ils avaient le choix entre se laisser
prendre donc risqué 5 à 10 ans voilà et
évidemment tu es etc pour se sauver
s'il avait la certitude à ce moment-là
qu'il devait être condamné à mort il
aurait choisi certainement la première
il n'est pas calculé
exactement à la fois monsieur lebon je
dis monsieur il faut ce n'est pas
l'instinct de conservation parce que si
il était certain d'être condamné à mort
il l'instinct de conservation l'aurait
conduit à se faire arrêter immédiatement
voyez donc l exemple de ce chemin et
c'est ce qui fait dire c'est parce qu'il
fait ça le fait pas reculer on ne
l'appliquent pas elles existent
n'applique pas non alors c'est pour ça
qu on l'apprend la brique rarement se
prononcer la ville aurait drogué cas
extraordinaires comme certaines choses
qui sont passés la lire quelques temps
et d elle reviendra cette peine de mort
avec eux ce qui se passe à l'heure
actuelle dans des cambriolages des
attaques de banques et des otages
elle reviendra et alors pour donner
l'exemple et peut-être qu'à ce moment là
le legend et ses gangsters y penseront
et reculeront sais tu rentres pas partie
est ce que vous croyez qu'un délinquant
jeunes délinquants qui devient criminel
pense à ce moment là si je fais ça je
risque ça si je fais ça je risque de
temps moi je pourrai compter de l'année
pas le droit de le tuer ou empêchera les
autres de doter d'autres s'adonnaient à
la peine de mort existait la france
était bien appliquées par abandonner ses
basses consommation extrêmement fort
c'est tout le monde et que l'on tient ça
pouvait jusque là tout autre chose ou
quelqu'un d'autre solution oui mais
enfin nous y sommes je crois jusqu'ici
vous regardez tous croient que nous
sommes des gens
mo moi quand je m'affole je donne une
claque à imphy jamais acheter draka
lesbien gl été amené à ce point là mais
il ya des limites
je vous dis pas le contraire mais nous
parler un gangster silane revolver dans
la main vous croyez que mokdad son
pistolet dans la main il va réfléchir ce
que je tire je ne pense pas que
l'exemplarité de la peine nous allons
nous servir de justification si j'ose
dire d'alibi je crois que si nous
condamnons lambert aussi nous le
condamnons pas fait nous lui accordons
nous n'accordons pas le bénéfice des
circonstances atténuantes c'est pas en
nous disant oui mais ça servira
d'exemple aux autres
je crois que c'est une mesure
individuelle que nous qui sommes douze
ici prendront contre lambert enfin faut
pas partir du point de vue que il a fait
une connerie pour il a fait ça est
entière il a fait sa connerie rien à
faire et doit payer mais faut pas
obligatoirement le tout fait pour ça
quand on parle de réinsertion dans la
société
si on parle d'un style lui même avait
employé le terme instinct et bien quel
que soit ce qu'on pourra faire pour lui
ses instincts restaurant êtes d'accord
les instants c'est quelque chose de très
profond et vous pouvez bien lui dire et
lui faire pour lui tout ce que vous
voudrez toute la douceur et toute la
gentillesse que vous pourrez avoir pour
lui ne change rien à ses instincts à q3
demain
nan qui n'étaient pas poursuivis à ce
moment
mesdames et messieurs les jurés alors
penser que nous pouvons passer au vote
alors je vous rappelle que le vote est
secret que les magistrats ont le droit
de vote mais que leur voix n'est pas
prépondérante
alors concernant la culpabilité pour que
la réponse soit oui il faut qu'il y ait
au moins huit d'entre nous qui
inscrivent eu oui sur leur bulletin
alors je vais vous demander de prendre
un bulletin de vote et d'inscrire oui si
vous estimez qu'il est coupable
non si vous considérez que lambert ne
l'est pas est un clip
c'est donc à l'unanimité il n'y a pas de
question nous venons de reconnaître
lambert coupable des crimes qui lui sont
reprochés
alors nous allons maintenant voter pour
savoir si nous devons ou non lui
accorder le bénéfice des circonstances
atténuantes
la majorité est la même pour que les
circonstances atténuantes
elle joue en sa faveur pour la
circonstance atténuante lui soit refusé
je dis bien refuser il faut qu'il y ait
huit nom sur le bulletin
si vous vous inscrivez non sur votre
bulletin vous soyez 8 à le faire lambert
sera déclaré coupable sans circonstances
atténuantes
la loi sera donc appliquée dans toute sa
rigueur
il sera condamné automatiquement à la
peine de mort sauf grâce présidentielle
éventuelle si vous voulez bien ce nom
prenez un niveau butin voulez-vous m non
si vous les refuser oui si vous les
accorder
oui une fois non non non non
non oui c'est la troisième victoire du
oui non oui non non oui
la cause
on s'est reprise oui vous asseoir
accusés mais c'était debout
voici les réponses aux questions et
l'arrêt des libérés un peu aussi
premières questions concernant la
culpabilité
la réponse a été oui la majorité de lui
voit où est la septième questions
concernant les circonstances atténuantes
la réponse a été non la majorité de huit
voix les réponses aux questions dont il
a été donné lecture vu les articles 2 12
295 3 sans 4 309 341 343 3 144 du code
pénal vu l'article 365 du code de
procédure pénale vu les articles 28 32
et 35 décret loi du 18 avril 1939
modifier la cour d'assises après en
avoir délibéré conformément à la loi
condamne lambert michel pierre à la
peine de mort
le condamne aux dépens verità accusé
vous disposez de 5 jours francs pour
vous pouvoir en cassation contre l'arrêt
qui vient d'être rendu par ce délai ne
seriez plus recevable car tu en es le
condamner l'audience est levée
où
[Musique]